hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
where I'm going be talking about finding
opportunity in the orderflow you know
around the highs or the lows of the day
and today specifically I'll be talking
about the lows of the day because we had
been in a pretty quiet session um slowly
grinding lower most of the session until
Nvidia came out and uh you know Market
jumped off the back of that but there
were some great opportunities um to buy
off the low of the day so before I jump
in if you enjoyed my videos don't forget
to subscribe and click the notification
Bell so you don't miss any new upload
and if you find today's video helpful be
sure to hit that like button and leave a
comment sharing your biggest takeaway I
love hearing your feedback you know your
support really does go a long way in
helping me create more videos all right
so let's jump into today's topic again
you know today was fomc so it's pretty
quiet session although we were grinding
lower um you know cash opened at 8:30
and we came down we touched our low that
we had made around 733 734 bounced off
that low that we had made earlier here
at 848 went up a bit but again kind of a
tight range you know our range for most
of the morning was
4973 to 4933 and a quarter 20 point
range you
know in the
snps is it's quiet now you know but
again it's in context of the market
we're trading around 5,000 in the S&P
you know when we're trading you know
1,00 1900 at 20 point range was a big
range but you know with the where we're
trading now in the market um 20 point
range which is is considered quiet um
fomc came out and we pushed down to new
lows and then we took off like a rocket
ship and you know Nvidia news came out
or earnings rather came out um and that
stock jumped up about
6% uh you know in uh in the aftermarket
but you know there was interesting
things happening in the orderflow down
here now I'm not you know suggesting
that your your Congressman was loading
up on S&P futures but uh you know what
made this load a much better buy than
you know any of these other loads that
we had put in so let's jump into it
let's go take a look at our footprint
chart you know um I love the footprint
chart because it it's a uh it's a
reading a gives you what traded on the
bid and the offer right the volume
traded on the bid the volume traded on
the offer and it's from that information
that you can make good trading decisions
all right so let's just go back to Cash
open well here it is Cash open right
here 8:30 and again kind of quiet right
it's fomc minutes uh day so we're going
to be waiting to see what uh the minutes
come out as and again you know based off
the minutes it it seems that a lot of
the participants were concerned about
the risks of cutting interest rates too
quickly you know I think that's why they
they sort of uh took it off the table
but really um you know I think the real
concern should be that they st stop
hiking rates too quickly you know um
you you know nowadays everything moves
in like quarter points you could still
raise you know 0.05 or something like
that but uh again I I do think we need
higher rates but anyway let's take a
look at some of this order flow that was
coming in here so you know 849 we hit
that low again you know it's sort I hate
to call this a double bottom um you know
because it's within uh you know two bars
one bar hits the low next bar
opens right near there and then then
trades that low but if we look earlier
right what time was that low made here
it was made at uh
735 okay now the volume was off that low
it was 306 traded there then you came
down you hit it again you know it's 183
this time though cash is open right and
volume is going to be much greater and
what was interesting is on this push
into this low we got some decent volume
8,743 contracts right and even the next
bar 7, um
395 and you know it was sort of our
heaviest volume since the cash open
where we traded
12,000 and the bar after that you got
what 9,000 but everything else is pretty
quiet okay so heavy volume into the low
couldn't go any lower strong negative
Delta again couldn't go any
lower bear in mind though it is fed day
so what does that mean if you got this
heavy selling coming in right strong
Delta minus 2300 that's strong this is
on a S&P one minute chart or rather 60c
chart 60 seconds one minute the same
thing can't push it lower okay then the
next Bar opens up we hit that low again
22 so we trade in the first time we hit
that low after the cash open 183 now
remember earlier we traded 306 that was
at 735 now it's and that's preach right
preash
opening now on a bar where you trade a
hell of a lot of volume
8,700 43 it only trades 183 on a bar
where there's heavy
selling what does that infer well infer
that you know sellers aren't interested
in taking it lower you don't have a lot
of sellers coming in there were some
strong selling earlier you see 1100 here
uh 400 400 400 600 400 400 80 183 you
know just sort of scrolling back here
this little bar here tra 306 1,500
contracts 306 traded at that low now you
got less Traders then even the next Bar
opens up 22 Lots trade down there okay
so what's that what do you think is
happening first time you hit that low
306 second time you hit that low 183
third time you hit that low 22 are
people interested in selling down here
no aggressive buying comes in you nice
positive Delta 737 and you just go
sideways to a little bit higher I mean
I'm not going to say it didn't rally
because you know where this this bar
closed up here 76 um it did trade all
the way up into the mid 80s you know
from 76 all the way up into you know the
the 83 in here um you know so seveno
move okay that's decent but again it's a
Fed day so you're not expecting big
moves seven points and I remember we
came into the session we had a 20 point
range so you just made back you know
that's a third of the range right there
on this on this little move up off that
low okay um
is it decent I know I mean a lot of
people would be happy with seven
points but again what was some of the
signs well the strong selling and can't
push the market any lower but more
importantly the selling into this low
was getting weaker just by watching the
volumes traded at those lows okay A
little bit of aggressive trading coming
in here with couple stacked buying and
balances in here and this Bar's actually
got one 2 3 4 five 6 7 8 9 10
10 yeah 10 buying imbalances in the bar
so you know there there's some strong
aggressive buying but again it's a Fed
day so you're not looking for a big
trending
move prior to the FED minutes coming out
so to get five six seven points out of
that move I I think it' be decent okay
then you know we just sort of drift down
again sideways sideways do make another
run up here back up into the mid 80s so
this time we get a little higher the 86
um but then let's take a look at uh this
low that we made down here at
11:15 okay make a new low by one
tick 86
one 86 trade on the first bar at 1114
1115 one contracts trades at that low
again not a strong low right it's just
it's almost like Traders are coming into
this low pushing it down seeing hey is
there you know going to take out the low
can we Trigg Tri some stops maybe this
Market could sell off some more it
doesn't Okay this time it rallies back
again from this low you know basically
goes from about 75 and a quarter you
know up to 77 and a half sideways down
into pushing now into some new lows at
11:45 now again you know what time is
the the minutes come out to come out at
1:00 right
so you know we're just sort of drifting
around lower it's not like you if you
were to see like strong selling coming
in ahead of the FED minutes I might be a
bit worried but um you know it to me
there's nothing overly strong um that
you'd want to all of a sudden turn short
and get short righted through the FED
minutes but um okay so we come down here
11:44 push down into some new lows start
bouncing up now on this move up here now
this I thought was interesting because
you have some decent signs of momentum
again just like you had earlier with a
strong aggressive buying two buying and
bounces here 1 2 3 3 4 here now you're
starting to get some single prints one
in here Z 8 so you know this Market's
got some momentum on its side it's
starting to go forward starting to Rally
up but again it's now 11:47 you got
about an hour and 20 minutes not even
before the fomc comes out so are you
going to be looking for a major move no
I mean if fed comes out and says
something weird yeah you probably get a
major move but are you going to bank on
that no I mean I I think you'd be a fool
to um try and do that you know but
that's me you know I'm erir on the the
side of caution but there is some some
signs of momentum coming in here with
the the lack of counter trade in the
thin PR showing here and again you get
this nice little move coming in here um
again not a big major move but again
it's you're coming into that time before
the FED minutes come out so do you want
to be doing it or not I I don't think so
um then here right 1202 right Market
slammed in here some strong selling okay
again timing now you got less than an
hour we do make a new low um we go from
70 down to 67 and 3/4s so about you know
two two two points in one
tick start ring up okay boom getting
ready again I I been around the markets
long enough to know it's fed day just
sit back and wait see what comes out um
you know what the FED says okay boom fed
comes out kind of a nothing Burger
surprisingly you know in terms of market
movement here you got this Market popped
up a bit you got you know some buying
and balances you got 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 you got you know a bunch of single
prints thin prints in here three a two a
zero a zero a seven so you got you know
1 two three four but that's to be
expected
all right that's is sort of the kneejerk
reaction after the FC minutes come out
give it a time to settle down Market
does settle down right one you know here
you can see it's not it's not going
crazy like you normally would see it on
a Fed day um so we come down into these
new lows this new low to me is is
nothing there's no strong reason to be
getting long here other than you know
the nice positive Delta and you know the
buying and balances but you know buying
and Balan is going you're going to end
up with a nice positive Delta anyway um
and it just sort of goes sideways starts
drifting down drifting down again we
start hitting new lows again down here
here now these are divergences right you
got a new low with positive Delta 74
64 2846 so you hit it once twice a third
time the the next two times after this
low it's very thin volume it's 4 and
six you got some bullish ratios of a 72
or 44 you know you could buy them those
I I like those I like that trade setup
it's the Divergence plus a bullish Delta
sorry a bullish ratio Market does rally
again goes from about 65 A2 here call
this 65 A2 gets all the way up to about
70 but not a big move okay now again
we're at our low and to me anytime you
have a reason to be buying at a low is
going to give you a good trading
opportunity and to me I I I felt that
this was a decent buying opportunity
unfortunately you only went up up up
about Five Points okay then came back
down starts testing these lows in here
and then boom you come down you make a
new low by about a point all the way
down to 61 and a quarter in the next bar
so um we go from
762 and 3/4 down to 61 and a quarter so
about point and a half starts popping up
again it looks like it wants to Rally
before it hits this new low here at
59 then you start really seeing the
bullish momentum coming in here and then
the market takes off and in this bar
here again I thought this was a good
buying opportunity only rallied about
Five
Points this one this
movement is just it's kind of normal
looking at at a low it's nothing that's
really going to get me interested to buy
it but off of this low here I I felt
that it was very strong momentum coming
in here
why because you make that low okay so
you're coming in hot into this new lows
coming into this low strong negative
Delta again - 685 then- 361 at the low
so you got strong negative Delta at the
low the nice big positive Delta and
again still a positive Delta but you got
five buying and balances but look at in
here right you got stacked buying and
balance as well 0 0 one you've got zero
a thin print a thin print a thin print
stack thin prints now sometimes when you
get stack thin prints it's the result of
Stack mining
imbalance maybe you're still not
convinced yet in here then three bars
later 1 2 3 you get e0 three right so
you're getting more thin prints coming
in off this
low and more importantly what do you
see okay you're seeing these selling
imbalances in here so you what does that
mean it's green candles with selling
imbalances well it's volume that is
absorbing whatever aggressive selling is
taking place in the market 100 then
again you know 34 against six you know I
could ignore that but 194 against 45 130
against 5 these are all little signs
okay and if you were to get long off of
this bar or even off of this bar here
similar things that happened earlier are
happening in this bar you know you're
talking 67 and then it just runs all the
way up into the 80s pretty quick now
again I'm not saying that you know you
would have held it all the way up to new
highs up in here at you know in the 90s
you know because the cash closed right
on the
high and hold it through Nvidia you know
this stuff you know you're not going to
be trading through anyway but there was
signs in here with the orderflow and and
this where having good software is going
to help you because look if you had
software that can just draw the stuff
for you draw these areas of importance
on here um where is it thin prints okay
enable thin print
here
and it's just going to draw out those
zones for
me right it's going whether it's a zero
print in this case I got it set pretty
um what do you call
it pretty strict at
oops I got I'm sorry guys I I'm doing a
uh upgrade on the software so I'm
testing it now on here we're going to be
releasing the upgraded version of um
orls Trader
soon
um but one of the things that I have to
make sure I got disabled on it when I'm
testing it is the the fast uh data
processing feature to draw out the zones
properly but um you're going to see it
appear in here right these zones from
what we call thin prints being drawn on
your chart right it's just going to give
you that visual so you don't have to sit
there and think you know is this does
this qualify as a thin print or not
because you're going to know right
away if it is you know so you can catch
those moves like this right here boom
boom
boom as soon as it's taking place
right because that that's really what
you want to be doing right is you want
to be buying as close to the low as
possible based off of what's taking
place in the order flow
okay that's the whole point of using
orderflow take advantage of it as
quickly as it comes because you know at
the end of the
day when you're looking at order flow
right what it is is what's trading in
the market right now okay when do you
want to take advantage of it well if
it's information that's coming to you
right now you want to take advantage of
it as quickly as possible okay so here
we go um sorry about that I I had to
pause the video there for a second
because uh I had an extra setting I had
to disable but um you can see it right
here thin print zero Z and one right
there's another zero and these are
coming in right off the low that is a
sign of momentum so you want to be
picking up on that you know as quickly
as possible and again you know there was
one here um one here but again you know
off these
lows do you want to be buying this this
one definitely not next bar doesn't even
go any higher again similar thing next
bar here doesn't go any higher when
you're looking at a thin print which is
a sign of momentum you want to be taking
advantage of it as quickly as possible
so the Market's got to start moving
right this the part that a lot of
Traders Miss is oh I got some bullish
order flow in here I got one two three
buying IM balances I got a thin print in
here I got to get long and then what
happens the market reverses and goes
down to make new lows well why would you
be getting long if we next bar can't
even go any higher okay but let's take a
look here at some of these other lows
here this one again no thin prints no
signs of momentum coming in it is ratio
and Divergence you get a little bit of a
move nothing um
spectacular here this low off of this
low off of um here you got one Thin
print okay you know is that enough I I
do
think you you want something more
juicier right and this one was was to me
much juicier because you got one two
three stacked neatly on top of each
other I mean whether it was spread out
the fact that you got three coming in
here 1 two this eight again I have my
thin print set at one right now if I had
set it at three you know I'd probably
have a couple more right you can see in
here where is it thin print right volume
of one if I wanted to set a little bit
higher you know three or or even nine or
10 um you know there' be more but look
at this two here one two here one here
right again if I had set it to cast The
Net a little wider at three I'd have two
in this bar as well
um let's go back to some of these other
lows here again off this low here right
after the
FED no there there's none in here right
and and usually that's time where it's
pretty volatile Market should be moving
um 1145 off this load again do you want
to take it you know so close to before
the FED announcement because again you
know you got to
realize any signs of getting long off
of the order flow or technical analysis
or however you're looking at the market
on a Fed
day you you got to take into account you
know how long can I hold this am I going
to hold this until the FED starts
talking or not you know in my opinion
it's going to uh limit
your possibilities let's go back to this
other low here at 8 here and nothing
major in here telling you really to get
long here you got one two three thin
prints all on the same bar right when
the market was popping up again from 81
you know up to 84 and a half and then
just went sideways on you so
basically point I'm trying to make today
is on this
video one don't trade ahead of the FED
minutes I mean you can I just don't
think it's prudent
but buying off of a low right again just
focusing
on the lows of the day here
right
here here nothing major to buy no I say
nothing major to buy I mean no major
reason to buy it in here but off of this
low down here there was a decent reason
to be buying it off here with the sort
of this triple
bottom single prints on these lows four
and six bullish ratios um bullish
divergences you get a little bit of a
move up
comes down makes this new low but this
low here at
222 right off of this low and again
doesn't have to be right on the low the
bar afterwards give you nice beautiful
Buy
Signal to catch that move up right and
it went from you know the low all the
way up to the highs of the day where the
market closed at okay so you know
Finding Your opportunities around the
edges of the Market meaning the lows or
the highs of the day um watch the order
flow watch what's happening right is
there a sort of this
shift in what's taking place in the
market in this case there was a shift in
momentum we saw the trading picking up
and the market had a nice rally off of
that all right everyone so I hope you
enjoyed this video sort of took me a
little bit longer to uh get to the point
that I was trying to make but um I hope
you found this video helpful to your
understanding of order flow and you know
the importance of watching how the order
flow um is building around the low of
the day all right everyone so take care
and I'll catch you guys on the next
video
bye-bye